[Musique]
en ce sondage vous êtes derrière zemmour
et vous dépasse
oui mais ce que vous remarquez aussi
c'est que marine le pen est à 16 et que
donc aujourd'hui il y a trois candidats
dans un mouchoir de poche absolument
aucune once d'inquiétude c'est ça
d'avoir l'expérience qu'est ce que je
vous dise pour la différence par rapport
à 2 selon roy d'expérience on peut
parfois être fébrile mais quand on a
l'expérience on sait qu'il suffit de
travailler si le kärcher avait été passé
zemmour n'existerait pas voilà c'est
aussi simple que ça donc zemmour un peu
comme trump aux états unis il lève le
couvercle et c'est ça à l'origine de son
succès extraordinaire aujourd'hui moi je
disais dimanche qu'ils pouvaient monter
jusqu'à 15% et dans les sondages
deuxième tour bien sûr on donnait
quelques centaines de milliers de vies
en 2019 et nu quelques dizaines de
milliers qu'on a beaucoup baissé en 2020
il faut dire qu'il a eu l'effet que
vides et là l'idée c'est de faire un
visa sur deux ça qu'on a un visa sur
deux voilà ça veut dire ça pour la
tunisie à un épisode 3 ème les mesures
sont totalement insuffisantes ce qu'il
faut faire ce que je ferai c'est d'abord
une loi constitutionnelle pour fixer des
quotas des quotas migratoires par pays
qui seront fixés chaque année par le
parlement de façon à reprendre le
contrôle de nos de nos flux migratoires
vous êtes couchée devant les centristes
depuis trente ans et c'est pour ça que
votre base vous a fui et que maintenant
vous vous retrouvez avec des candidats
que ce soit bertrand au pécresse ou
barnier qui sont en fait des candidats
pour être premier ministe de macron et
nous on leur dit tant que vous ne
reprenez pas vos compatriotes eh bien on
accepte pas vos compatriotes
c'est
votre bassin le port non non non sinon
victoire donc à la primaire écolo pour
yannick jadot vous savez depuis hier en
fin d'après-midi 51% des voix face à
sandrine rousseau et yannick jadot qui
en était le favori des je vais le dire
de manière très claire c'est yannick
jadot ne gagnera pas sans la dynamique
que moi j'ai créé
ne vous écoute pas vous iriez c'est ça
que c'est ce que je vais tester
maintenant c'est honteux ce qui se passe
avec bmc c'est un truc mais c'est
n'importe quoi de faire de faire ce jeu
là je trouve ça d'un d'une toxicité
total d'autres identités ne s'est jamais
bâtie sur le rétrécissement
ni à des prénoms ni à des formes de
crispation
la france a toujours écrit sa propre
histoire mondiale elle fait toujours
penser universellement n'a pas parlé
d'une personnalité ou d'un candidat il a
parlé de la france il a parlé de ce qui
fait la nation c'est-à-dire l'état note
roland il est dans son rôle de président
de la république dans un lieu culturel
quand il s'exprime sur ces sujets là n'y
voyez pas d'autres références eric
zemmour a raison et la raison quand il
dit qu'il existe au sein des lr
aujourd'hui de droite irréconciliables
et je pense qu'il y en a une qui n'est
plus républicaine si ce n'est de nom et
une qui reste républicaine il bénéficie
par don d'une indulgence d'une impunité
intellectuelle et qui est indigne de la
part de d'une atmosphère parisienne qui
en d'autres temps a su être beaucoup
plus violente à l'égard de tel ou tel
propos qui pouvaient éventuellement
choqué ayant un nom qui revient et qui
aimerait bien aller débattre ça
s'appelle rachida dati beaucoup d'élus
les républicains ont dit et si on
faisait monter rachida pour aller
combattre et mourin ça lui plairait
d'aller contre lui on se rappelle la
polémique à l'aise et morales avaient
attaqué sur son prénom le prénom de sa
fille et c'est ces gens là font
diversion avec avec ce qu'il propose
avec des contrevérités historiques comme
celle que monsieur zemmour dit sur vichy
les
quatre majeurs si vous voulez pour la
france
[Applaudissements]
au cours de l'hiver
word sound great balls of her à cela de
nos actions